on this episode we come to charity water
and get deep
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ask Gary B
[Music]
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode two ten of the ask
gary vee show I'm excited about this one
India we have a phenomenal guest dear
friend of mine for a very long time I
know a lot of you in the vaynernation
will know the organization and this
fine-looking gentleman as well let's go
for all the people at home that don't
know who are you and then tell us a
little bit about where we are and what
you do and then India we will get into
the show hope everybody had a wonderful
weekend of feeling good it's a nice day
in New York Jeremy on charity:water
based here in Tribeca in New York City
we've been at it for about ten years
trying to make sure every single person
on earth drinks clean water and
unfortunately people that are
undereducated yeah like I used to be
before we ran into each other how many
of those people exist that don't have
clean water so there are six hundred and
sixty three million people living around
the world without access to clean water
so it's about 1 in every 10 or 11 people
on the planet and yeah this is a
challenging issue because no one faces
this problem here you know our kids
don't drink dirty water our moms don't
walk eight hours with 40 pounds of
NASA's water that so it is it is a
really foreign problem to us but it's
it's real it exists and it affects you
know about a tenth of the planet
and when the charity:water begin the
almost five years ago on my 31st
birthday in September September 7th so
we're coming up on our tenth anniversary
and it began because I saw this problem
you and I actually grew up very close to
each other in a County baby I I moved to
the city at 18 or 19
you know rebelling against a very
conservative Christian upbringing in a
family only the nightlife
so I basically got off the desert he's
gonna under play this this guy is a
amongst legend in that world so I got
people drunk for 10 years I've got very
very good at the the velvet rope and the
one-way glass and the great DJs and all
the right people in the party and had
picked up pretty much every vice that
you can imagine short of heroin after a
decade of partying and just hit kind of
bottom at the top realized that I had
become the worst person I knew I was a
morally doing unable you were unable to
look around and say that guy is worse
than me it was that's that is actually
like I was doing the worst guy people
don't believe this like I know I have to
go find a little footage and you know I
find these old emails sometimes that I
wrote and just like what what hey waiter
what a jerk I was I remember once I mean
this really this is horrible number like
snow when delivered food once whatever
version of cause I think it's cosmic
babe
yes and someone delivered something and
they asked me to sign it and I didn't
have they had a pen and I spent like
five minutes yelling at them right for
not how you make me man like do you know
there's there's only one thing you need
to do which is bring a pack I was that
guy you guys was like that's a real bad
place I gots a really bad place it's
like hey Bobby you sprung up to a
totally different version so big life
change came back to faith but but really
interested me service and service of the
poor and and kind of living the opposite
values that I was living my life of
selfishness and decadence and I made a
radical change I sold everything I owned
down on my DVD collection and put it up
on a lot and eBay like fifteen hundred
DVDs yeah and I I make tough back then
kids you know Haven at multiples that so
and then I wound up imagining what would
the opposite of my life look like
and that would be service to the poor
serving someone else except myself I'm
actually been here for a second
in the context of the business show and
for a lot of you that are you know this
man helped me change the way I viewed
I'll never forget it told me
you know you know Gary you're gonna be
the kind of guy who's gonna do really
well in them in your older years you're
gonna deploy that wealth and do good
things why don't you just start doing it
now completely changed not only the way
I give but the a lot of things in my
life in it it's a very few people have
been able to penetrate me and change me
in any way you guys you're the own time
I don't even talk about my parents lack
of ability to at times do that so what I
find most fascinating about that and
this is for all of you entrepreneurs and
hustlers because I know you can watch
the skills that made him the best at
getting the hottest models and the best
bottles and the best places and the best
DJs he has been able to bring that
marketing that charisma that operation
skills to a world of good and I've been
blown away and intrigued so I've also
gotten involved pop and Penn so the
promise of other show me people that
have the skills that would work in the
profit sector and deploy them in the
nonprofit cause NGO whatever you want to
call it sector and you'll show me a
place that I'm more intrigued by because
it's got that entrepreneurial DNA
hustler ship watching you navigate over
the last decade getting the people
together that have become involved in
this organization it's all the same
skills that so many of you are trying to
attract to deploy for success for
yourselves and for the ones that are
watching like myself that you've gotten
into a place where maybe you've
scratched some of those edges and you
want to do other things with your life
now whether that is for cause or things
that makes your who that your family
members who ever understanding deploying
that same energy and DNA against the new
mission at hand
I've watched you build this organization
from afar with your amazing team and so
many of the tactics the strategies the
executions are predicated on things that
are tried-and-true and entrepreneurial
and and and nightclub culture things of
that nature so when it was story taught
me for 10 years I told the story that
your life had meaning if you got past
the velvet
and you were sitting with the pretty
girls and the pre boys and you were
popping five-dollar bottles of champagne
or in a table where that was nice so
that was the wrong story yes of my life
it took me to a really dark place and
I've been fortunate to be able to tell a
different story that you know if you are
generous if you are a compassionate if
you show empathy for others if you live
your life in servants in your time and
your talent and your money in the
service of others then your life is
warming and that you find you know you
find freedom actually outside of the
selfishness like when you serve others
there is a freedom that comes with that
and I was fortunate to find my way out
so long story short I sell everything I
try to apply to humanitarian
organizations and of course no one will
take me like this they're serious people
yes these are like serious people with
suits and degree than that they've come
out of you know huge UN agencies in the
World Bank you know I cannot get it I
can't get a volunteer job and then
finally one organization said if I paid
them five hundred dollars a month and I
was willing to go live in Liberia on a
hospital ship I could volunteer and I
was very fortunate to see that I could
turn the fifteen thousand people in my
club list that I've gotten drunk for a
decade and just tell him a news story
and they wanted to help so I'm running
around with the camera talking about the
problems that we're seeing the people
that were sick the the intervention of
these doctors who were transforming
lives and then I stumbled upon this
water problem and where with all we saw
sickness everywhere you know doctors
were leaving their vacations behind
instead coming to operate in to take
care of sick people in Liberia but yet
half the country didn't have clean water
so I'm like well if 50% of the people in
the country are drinking from swamps and
ponds and rivers how come no one is
talking about this you know how come the
biggest water only organization in the
country ten years ago is raising 50
million bucks a year and actually I
found water through health and later
learned it impacts education it impacts
the local economy it gets time back to
women waters this amazing amazing
foundational thing but at the time it's
just like well people are gonna be sick
if they are drinking dirty water and in
fact 53 percent of all disease
throughout the developing world
because of bad water in like the toilets
she gets played doctor to half of the
sick people in the world so it was a
compelling issue for me I'm still that
attenders later probably but you've done
some really great work we'll get into
more that work but India I think for the
people that are looking for some
questions and answers that a piss-up now
let me say on your idea for people
they're listening yeah that idea of
giving while you're building it yes it's
it's the traditional model with the
Buffett mommy right make all this money
and then you know in your old wise age
give it all away yes the fun that he
missed out on he's probably having fun
now watching Gates spend some of his
money but you get to live vicariously
there all these organizations yes
support and I know you've also supported
with thought capital and I've asked you
for introductions before so even more
than money and then I would encourage
anyone listening to find something you
know you don't have to be able to write
a huge check but don't wait on till the
end because the world is a better place
for a small percentage that have been
successful the money is easier part the
social equity of passing on a
relationship the sitting and planning
and strategizing than having drinks and
navigating how you're navigating through
the organization those are the real
things India let's get into this very
important show yes
president Taylor Taylor asks what's been
the biggest key in establishing charity
waters story how have you been able to
connect so well oh man I think the
biggest key was understanding what
people thought was wrong about cherries
and I think that's true for a lot of
entrepreneurs they start and say what
what what's what problem you know am I
trying to say I apologize for a lot of
people and there's so many youngsters
and these are the things that maybe
you've just aren't aware of one of the
things that people start really worrying
about is wait a minute if I give a
dollar why is the cause only getting 14
cents yeah why is the thing only getting
31 cents you start on winding wait a
minute big salaries bureaucracy politics
you know kickback look really gnarly
stuff and and that is absolutely you
know take it from somebody who came from
very little when you work your face off
to amass what you have if you're giving
it away the things you really want to
feel good
where it's going and a lot of people
struggled with that I would say that was
an absolute pillar for you guys and that
was problem number one so 42% of
Americans don't trust sherry I think
about that we have this amazing heritage
is this giving us country week we are in
America but almost half of the people
that could get don't trust the system
and it's all around money yeah so that
was really proud of them right I don't
trust the mainstream system and a lot of
people don't believe I actually have
said this I actually think you and two
or three others biggest impact ever is
that you guys have become the cool
versions for the next generation and
every kid growing up right now wants to
have an organization that's more
transparent and that you guys will all
solve and tackle and move the ball in
your causes but your impact on all the
13 to 22 year olds right now that look
up to three or four organizations that
are the most progressive that you live
been at the forefront of I think your
impact is far greater on what you do to
the entire landscape of NGOs then just
the mission you have here well that was
the vision at the beginning was to
reinvent sherry so most people just know
us through the mission yep and I believe
those are very different the mission is
to give clean drinking water make sure
there's a day when we are not doing this
interview talking about water right kids
who are about the same age or growing
out and like next my team is not coming
into their school showing pictures of
kids reading nasty water so that's the
mission but you're right the vision was
to do charity differently charity is a
virtue and you know there's a lot of
talk these days about like good
businesses and right out to be there is
a role at a place for pure philanthropic
capital you know there are companies out
there that are trying to solve the water
crisis through selling bottled water
they sell a $2 and 30 cent bottle of
water and five cents goes okay well then
it's better just again a bunch of people
to give five cents or you know instead
of buying the water so I mean I believe
there's a place every model you have
certain people that start with a good
mission at hand where buy one give one
and then every huckster comes along and
here I want to raise 15 million dollars
for my umbrella
but it Gary good news for everybody buzz
an umbrella I'm gonna give a novela some
kid that doesn't need it so it becomes
tactics over religion but that was it so
100% of the public's money would be the
way we'd solve it we would go find a
group of visionary people who didn't
distrust charity and we would get them
to fund the staff and the operations
that we would have that's a group of 110
people today many who have been on your
show I know you and your wife have been
long-term supporters of that but it's a
very simple model there are two bank
accounts 110 people pay for the overhead
a million people have been able to give
the pure way so we say you don't trust
where the money's going how about that's
a hundred percent of your money we even
pay that credit card fees it's cost us
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
so if someone were to give a hundred
rocks on there a man because Lizzie and
I you can give your seventeen dollars
and every one of them I'm not joking and
every one of those pennies ghosts and we
only get seventeen we get 1681 we
actually seek your money to make up the
difference so that every dollar can go
to the field and then we was trying to
18 cents t we we just tried to connect
people to the impact that was having
because money was not fungible because
he's honored yes his bank accounts were
separate than they were audited
separately we could track dollars so I
can say to a kid you know to your
daughter you you birthday Tiffany she
can see the actual photos in GP I see I
wouldn't tell him and I was need to move
this along the birthday campaign I don't
want to miss it before we get into it
this was a monumental thing from afar
from a marketing state we stumbled into
it but just instead of getting the full
story you can look this up and google it
but give them at least what it is people
instead of throwing a party or accepting
gifts because we have enough crap and we
get stuff we don't even need for our
birthday we don't really need a party
it's your 33rd birthday you donate it
and you ask for your agent dollars right
so you have a three year old up sender
email bus social media post instead of
getting me a gift gift $33 to this and
seven year olds ask for $7 any nine year
olds ask for $89
million people get water I'm just gonna
say what has been the impact of this
campaign the average person raises
$1,000 from 15 of their friends so Trey
Madison the idea a million birthdays
could be a billion dollars for clean
water right because not everybody gives
just $33 a my 33rd birthday somatically
euro come give three bucks right there
any sense but every dollar goes and then
everyone who's the first where it goes
so I was birthday number one on my 32nd
but then this 7 year old kid in Austin
starts knocking on doors and here is his
22 grand and then we like fell on crap
and then Jack Dorsey did 3 birthdays and
Will Smith that their birthday and
anyway with an eighty nine year olds no
no ween
gave up her 89th birthday and wrote a
mission statement and said you know I'd
like other people to have the chance
that's for Haiti not yeah it's a really
beautiful idea our birthdays can help
other people actually have more
birthdays so yeah you can actually
pledge charity whatever org slash
birthdays even if it does a year from
now you've done them I've done seven now
your kids you have a great thing $26.50
yeah Donna you're a [ __ ] lay it asks
what should people look for in a charity
to know that donations are going to a
good cause
let's you know what let's go very
utilitarian here because I've got a
heart stoppage charity navigator dot org
mr.kidding this I'm off but you can read
navigate org you can you can check out a
charity however overhead is a good
trainer and then go read Dan Pilates
work and down with me book is unsure so
there's two things you can get the
numbers of how a charity spends its
money and you can create more cynicism
by reading the book one you get a
different view reading the book saying
that overhead is not bad
and then we've made our head back we
have over it 110 people cover it God so
then looking at how much of your money
what we push for his transparency I'm
happy to give to a charity where twenty
five cents of my dollar and my code it
was smart team running good programs I
don't want a fifty percent of my dollar
I don't want ninety percent of money I
want to know actually let's take that
because it's a slippery slope if you
know me very very well if like if I said
I'm the marketing genius of a generation
but I need the other 17 I need d-roc
nice fancy now he makes movies like I
need fifty cents a dollar but I'm gonna
kill it
do you think you can wrap your head
around that in theory you could right I
mean it's it's so damn glad would and
that's that is one campus you many think
members I mean you're so close to it
that feels so aggressive but at some
level I guess the energy of it could be
the punchline is if you can feel that
the overhead actually justifies the
mission at yet but that's it so the
transparency is what we're pushing for
so you might be willing to write a
hundred thousand dollar check and have
50 grand go yes the problem is so many
people don't know how many sample that's
right but I may not be or maybe you and
I are both willing but if you're like
now fifty cents is too much it's the
that's the only thing we've been pushing
for
I'm not telling people to adopt 100%
model it works for us because you're
able to train yourself
well members that have covered that's
right and people give for the first time
I hear all the time this is the first
chair will give that
I just heard it last week so on Twitter
made the first chair we'll get to Maya
hey that's a little sad but that's the
kind of person I want I don't know I
would argue it's not sad I think back to
that 42% I was a grown man with a lot of
thoughts and a very decent dude when we
said forget about my downstairs me you
and Sokka at that pool place and you
said that statement and it right now you
have what schools in your name yeah not
just this and instead of boards and do
other things like it changed the way I
thought about it in the same way that is
my hope and dream that a 28 year old
hustler right now who's made a couple
bucks doing snapchat filters cuz he got
my advice 40 episodes ago to do that
says you know what I'm gonna donate $28
right now and give away my 29th birthday
or whatever and by the way I don't judge
you do what you want to do you wanna be
90 and never give a dollar everybody
does what they do you're missing out you
can really have it's fun it's a blessing
together I mean this is like we were
flying it up is growing up
it is you get to live vicariously
through all of the good your time and
your money is doing doesn't need to be
charity water I get it yeah I guess it's
it's a blast it's a blast
Melissa asks I do work in Uganda after
clean water
is creating sustainable jobs the best
way to see impact I think they're a
bunch of pillars people need you believe
that when water is thrilled it opens up
the whole gamut
I do but jobs are incredibly important
shelter is important food is an
important health is important we've just
started with water cuz I get to touch
jobs we hear these amazing stories of
women who would use the time back in
their day specifically actually in
Uganda sentence and they will sell rice
at the market they'll sell peanuts I was
in lace again by the way we're going
very quickly here until we roll that's
how the show rules but I know my
audience guys when he says gas when he
says time back these are women who would
walk three hours because an hour there
30 minutes 20 minutes to swing took the
wrath water rap brown and then walk back
it's 40 billion hours are wasted just in
Africa collecting water let me talk
about the workforce so yes they did a
study 88 page study out of the UN every
dollar invested in water sanitation
makes the community four to eight times
richer it yields four to eight dollars
so jobs are incredibly important and
that's one of the things that's
attractive to us about water concern
without the time well so thanks for the
work you do awesome Nayeli asks what's
the best way to fundraise for a church
that is also a community center with
limited resources so let's break out of
our thing and go more holistic yeah sure
one more time what's the best way for
that charge for a church that is also
the best church canteen that ever
happened was the church camp I don't
know what kind of church she goes to but
this was a pretty young hipster pastor
in Seattle and he was trying to show his
community that they actually weren't you
know over religious so he threw a keg
party and he got a local band and he
created a smoking session outside the
church and they raised over $500,000
because the community wouldn't
necessarily have given to the church but
he actually chose us because we were not
a faith based charity he chose us to
make a statement and say look our church
community we care about the world we
care about clean water but we don't need
to do it with strings we don't need to
do it with an agenda so I think that's a
that message resonated powerful with the
Seattle community one of the things now
we're trying to get entire churches to
donate the birthday of every single
person in the church same thing you know
your friends Gary's not going to give to
my church community but he would give to
my clean water campaign and it's it's a
great way to kind of reach outside the
walls and build bridges I think it comes
down and it was brought up right from
the beginning it's storytelling right
like what does your community care about
what is going to compel them to donate
you know understand the context of the
people that are part of the church
community you need to understand the
people that are outside the community
and I still believe in the context of
this show there's many ways but in the
context of this show I think getting
very aggressive around snapchat and
coming the best snapchat player in a
small town in South Carolina as a church
and then going to the local newspaper to
write an article about how this church
is doing snapchat better than anybody
it's always using new mediums that give
awareness to your mission at hand
through your execution of that
storytelling and so whether it's
snapchat or something else
live-streaming on Facebook live for 72
straight hours something that everybody
in the world is talking about use that
platform to get you awareness over what
you're doing wait a fundraiser
run campaign where he listened to
Nickelback for seven straight days day
and night he went to sleep with
headphones on he raised $35,000 in
sympathy from a community and and I
would say 23 sorry yeah or snapchat to a
team in Berlin a few days ago who did a
take over a charity water snapchat and
they were running marathons and banging
on yellow jerry cans not that we would
have never thought of they were
spray-painting jerry cans creating art
creating content you know what I I know
I've got a run in there you've got a run
but in the last two minutes
what's that okay in the last couple of
minutes here what do we not cover for
the vaynernation to know about you
charity water yeah so 10 years you know
we're getting reflective we've helped 6
point 1 million people out of 660
million so we're about 1% of the global
problem is that crippling to you like
I'm no it's like you know what let's go
yeah listen to the other side of min or
two I'm sitting here thinking about I'm
very fortunate because I've been close
enough to watch and we don't hang out
every day but I'm watching right
boy you fossil and for me to say you've
hustled like then I need six blades you
know you know like to me that's like a
very difficult place to go for me to
like put one on
I respect your hustle that's hard for me
to go there I really respect your hustle
for as hard as you grind first many
conversations selling people one by one
selling the story
how many flights a year and you're
almost a hundred yeah I mean that he
said these are not like what I do like
hey man we've never bought a
business-class ticket into history so
like you know I really watched from afar
and very honestly and this is a good
opportunity for me to say this publicly
you did such a good job selling me my
level of cynicism starting off is like
when's the other shoe gonna drop right
we've talked about this some personal
level I get it from the business advice
then I started having kids first hard as
you puzzled first talented as you've
done for all these crazy names that have
been associated for although all the big
impacts the charity events the the gala
in different ways you've done it you
know boy for everybody who's watching
that I've seen patience patience
patience it's got to be a little bit
disheartening that you're a decade in
and 1% of the problem I don't believe
knowing how ambitious you are and
optimistic as I am as well that's good I
don't think you would have sat there ten
years ago and if we were buddies from
Hunterdon and I said bro weird thing I'm
a GE and ten years we're gonna be
sitting with Indian d-roc and I'm gonna
tell you you've got you crushed it
you've got as smart as you thought you
ready to go and great news you you move
the needle by one person so it's tough
you know I actually appreciate the you
access because most people take the
other tack and they say did you have any
idea you would be so successful did you
have any idea you guys from a cold start
would raise a quarter of a billion
dollars from a million people who didn't
trust cherry and like Scott you
transformed 19,000 communities through
yogurt your community has you've been a
catalyst to 19,000 communities in 24
countries in 6.1 million lives and I was
like dude I thought we'd be 10x I
thought you know it would be 50 million
people served by now so it's it's hard
as least as the beginning is hard to get
people to care about like it's hard
like your eggs aren't drinking dirty
water your mom never walked eight hours
because people lived thousands of miles
away you're not selling the product they
are not useful
you know the poorest people trapped in
the water crisis are not useful to
they're not gonna buy our product into a
crazy question that it's another another
thing that nobody would ask you I'm
sitting or not listening and then I'm
also thinking about all the emails I get
every day emails that I'm on welfare I
own $400,000 for student loans my dad
died last week and I have to provide I
get some pretty normally you never
should give through a lot of yeah but
that's actually not where I'm going I'm
sitting here thinking they're watching
this and they've got their own problems
they're you know I sometimes think about
the people that are less fortunate in my
inner circle friends I grew up with
college buddies relatives this is a
really funny question I love doing what
I do in a very narrow world with far
more vanity and less nobleness than what
you're up to no question because I love
the way it makes me feel by making a
less money but making somebody emailing
me and saying you've made my business
like better I get a high from that do
you believe and this is where I'm poking
at the audience a lot of people don't
have a lot of money a lot of people are
in debt yet they're very comfortable
buying a $600 iPhone while still in that
circumstance just true let's call it
what it is do you think it's actually
innately human to not understand do not
be why this is a real serious question
maybe and I'm curious from your
perspective and I don't believe you
actually have the answer I want your
opinion do you think people are
inherently selfish because I would say
that's wrong but do you think people
don't get off or get a high from giving
because I do and I know it's my biggest
advantage I actually think I have all my
things because I was blessed with the
DNA of the high of giving I I say 5149
in busy
all the time I genuinely want the
leverage and the feeling of giving more
than getting in return because I'm good
do you think that that is an actual
human hardwiring that most people feel I
cool whatever bro you're right it's not
in my face then you know my problems I
need to I need escapism I'm gonna buy
Netflix instead of helping some kid I
don't know in a country that I don't
hear about
I think selfishness is easier in the
default I think you know like being a
dad now like seeing how selfish my
little human being is yeah you know and
then and kind of training him about
sharing and patience and all these like
their muscles that have to work however
I think the more you give the more you
want to give it unlocks something you
know we talked here about getting
addicted together right you start giving
to us right then you started getting new
pencils and you started giving to others
I mean you're like wait this is kind of
cool and now I can give some time and
now I can give some connections so it's
one of those things it's the more and
it's not about the mic there are people
watching it might be able to give five
dollars what what I've been amazed at is
some of the some of the people in the
greatest need are the most generous and
that is what that is what perplex me we
did a Kennedy and early on the Saks
Fifth Avenue and you know it's a very
simple idea right women come in and buy
$5,000 handbags let's also get the new
sponsor water projects you thought this
is not to be a home run well it was
however what was the most inspiring
thing that Saks went up raising $700,000
to their community but the employees in
the Jackson Mississippi call center
started selling their personal jewelry
to raise enough money so that a well
could be built on behalf of the call
center and to CEOs like these people are
many of them are a minimum wage right
it's the rich that are supposed to be
giving it's the women that are you know
maybe buying a $5,000 a handbag that
would feel guilty that people know it's
and that is that is inspiring that's you
latch on to that it's like the Widow's
mite those are the stories that we are
talking about 2,000 years later you know
that people working out so I think
giving is an exercise the more you do
give time and give talent give money the
more you do the more you want to do and
the more changes you for the better the
more changes your family the more it
impacts your legacy
thanks for everything did of course
every guest gets to ask the question of
the day a lot of people answer what
question do you have for the audience
okay question a question that you would
like in situ and said look you your
being this will Ito hopefully inspires a
small group to maybe do something
instead of that route
is there something genuine like some
insight on we have hundreds and hundreds
of people could yes look at you two so
our challenge is we've got a million
people to give once over the decade
we've helped six million people we start
at zero every year January one we have
to go do it all over again we have to
reinstall people you know I mean go
remind him that his family is making a
difference we're trying to build a
monthly Giving Program we're trying to
build a subscription program and
innovate and we actually don't know how
yet the sponsored child model everybody
is familiar with 30 years ago a bunch of
charities said if i hook Gary up with a
kid Sally he's gonna stay for ten years
I don't know that kid Sally yeah right
and you're not going to stop giving $38
a month because Sally might be on the
street yeah there's a very powerful idea
that connection we're starting with a
white piece of paper what does you know
what does it look like for charity water
to take a million people who gave once
and get him to give 5 bucks a month $1 a
month 30 bucks a month 100 bucks a month
and bring them along for the next ten
years to make a 10x impact and we don't
know what that experience is like we
have twenty four hundred and seventy
monthly givers we just broke a million
dollars which is you know about one
fiftieth of the revenue of the or
or the donation revenue what is the
experience look like so we love people
could check out our programs business
thinkers what does he do here's what
would you what would you want that
excites you to give seven bucks a month
or thirty bucks can give one person
clean water so there's some people
listening to get thirty 30 bucks a month
and at the end of the year they gave
twelve people clean water we can show
them what that desert what what what
sticks like where you're in six months
right and you phone a hard time so
you're gonna pay your Netflix bill
you're gonna pay your Spotify bill
here's what actually happens people will
lose their credit card and they won't
Reese I not for the guinea how would we
make that such a compelling program how
do we inspire people for the next decade
so then instead of just the drive by
hedge saw this podcast that's cool
where's yeah yeah that's it's every
month we can count on it and we can plan
for the future
so we're piloting it we got twenty four
and seventy people we don't let anybody
to join but if you have ideas I'm gonna
we have a whole team working on it
you keep asking questions
this man will continue to change the
world sup guys hope you enjoyed the show
please do I get the link it up anywhere
is it like in here or is it down below
is it in print or is it in my video it's
here down to my left
like right here there's a button for
them to subscribe to my youtube video
yeah it's a little buggy thing that's
right guys
click this that's right use that